hi I'm Bill Gates and these are moments
from my life Paul Allen who's the
co-founder of Microsoft and I are at
Lakeside High School and that's a
teletype terminal that connects over a
phone line to a GE Time short computer
where you can write basic programs I was
13 when that teletype showed up and I
had done super well in a math exam you
know best in the state
so Paul who was 2 years ahead of me when
the computers kind of complicated he
kind of challenged me to say hey you
know math can you figure this out and so
he and I became good friends
despite that age difference and you know
Paul had read a lot of science fiction
and knew a lot of things I didn't so our
friendship and partnership started up
from that time forward and in this
computer room the teachers had come in
and tried to figure it out but they
ended up wasting a lot of money and so
we kind of took over the the computer
room and taught the other kids how to
program we're writing huge complex
programs and basic trying to solve hard
problems a lot of kids were interested
at first but there were a small group
that stayed just in day and night using
the thing it's still there
my daughter who goes to that school
calls it the shrine so this is kind of
an array of different computers there
were a lot of personal computers way
before the IBM PC that comes out in 1981
Microsoft had its software on all of
them the Apple - the Commodore pad the
Radio Shack trs-80 about a dozen
machines that were done in Japan you
know we worked on a ton of come machines
we were spreading the idea that these
microprocessor based machines would be
revolutionary the one right here was the
first portable computer that's a eight
line LCD with 32 characters across
that's called the model 100 that's the
last piece of software that I was the
primary engineer and then I you know
sort of more managed people well I still
coded but this is the project where I'm
totally in charge now
so figuring out how to fit into a 32k
byte wrong a floating-point basic and a
text editor or an a director manager so
that was a super fun very difficult
project so I wrote code you know even to
this day I do some architecture things
on the the various products but yeah I
missed the elegance of you know writing
super tight code almost nobody does that
now cuz memory is so big people can be a
bit more sloppy than you could be back
then the microprocessor
had been coming along and Paul in 1971
showed me the four thousand four which
is the first Intel product and we talked
about Moore's law I'd written basic for
a lot of many computers that were still
quite expensive and when he showed me
the 8080 I said no it's not good enough
but the 8080 that's 1973 that was good
enough for me to do a basic interpreter
so you know that became our first
product and that was you know that was
the revolution that was the thing that
assured in personal computing the
creation of Microsoft and being part of
the personal computer industry and you
know then the internet and all that
great things that come out of that and I
feel super super lucky to have had a
central involvement along with thousands
of others in in those days well Windows
95 was a big milestone for the company
this series of events was a immensely
fun for everybody who's involved because
we had been working day and night these
were pretty maniacal days in terms of
work was everything even you know I
didn't believe in weekends or vacations
the team pretty broadly had worked super
super hard the marketing people had
figured out how to take this phenomena
and you know get create a lot of
excitement around it you know we all
over the world we had things being lit
up in the windows colors we had big
events all over the world there have
been a lot of anticipation because the
beta test was literally hundreds of
thousands of copies of this thing and
all the developers who had written
applications for it were waiting because
the memory capacity you got in this
generation machines was so much better
than what came before this was the
ushering in of the graphics interface
moving from character mode which all the
Dass worked before this had been to this
graphics mode and Windows 95 on the PC
and then the Mac OS on the Mac were
bringing graphics interface into the
mainstream it had been sort of invented
at Xerox PARC with some very expensive
low volume type machines but Windows 95
you know we brought office across and
this product was phenomenally successful
caught on in a big wage windows itself
I had bet the company on all the way
back in 1983 and so there's 12 years of
getting the windows concept to be faster
and the processors are getting better
and here clearly had arrived and there
was no doubt that versus anything else
out there this was the mainstream of
computing and all the developers were
there to to take full advantage of it
yes so this is a Melinda who I was not
yet married to at the time although we
were engaged we're out on the the
Serengeti for our first trip to Africa
and we're kind of looking around we have
took a bunch of friends with us it was
the first long vacation I'd ever taken
it was a two-week vacation which seemed
quite extreme to me but it was you know
great fun and very eye-opening it's
important because it's you know the
start of our marriage but also some of
the insights that led to the foundation
being focused on health of the poorest
particularly in Africa came from the
curiosity about the people and you know
we're living in very tough conditions
and so subsequent to this she and I did
a lot of reading with this idea that
okay someday the Microsoft wealth was
gonna go back to the public and what how
you know the lens towards innovation and
I'm really helping those most in need
how could we do that well in you know in
Microsoft my early partner was Paul
Allen and then Steve Ballmer was my
partner now Melinda's you know even a
totally equal partner and all the
foundation work we're doing so she she
and I run it together it was so
fascinating I mean the relationships we
were building learning all this new
stuff to have somebody to brainstorm
with about it you know made it a lot
more fun you know things like writing
letters together giving speeches
together we had to learn how to bring
out the best of the both of us and in
doing those things but yeah it was
always you know clear we wanted to do it
together
[Music]
yeah we're backstage at the Microsoft
CEO conference and Warren's telling me a
story about a business that he had
invested in you know was a guy call him
on the phone you know trying to tell him
he had an investment that Warren should
make and Warren was explaining why it
was pretty clearly not something that he
was gonna waste money on he's such a
been such a great friend and you know so
clever and I've learned so much from him
you know he's got an amazing sense of
humor well I was very lucky that we were
introduced and it was 1991 where I was
quite reluctant to take any time away
from work within a few minutes of
meeting him he was asking questions
about why could Microsoft compete with
IBM and what were the dynamics and our
business there were really amazingly
good questions that nobody really had
asked before and then I could ask him
about his broader view of business and
so we you know we became great friends
right from that that first meeting well
a hobby of mine so I was playing tennis
and so it was it you know real privilege
to do a fundraising event where I was a
doubles partner with Roger Federer well
you know he's gonna take care of it you
practice saying yours as loud as you can
and actually when an amateur's playing
in something like this moving up to the
net is particularly valuable because you
can hit quite attractive shots up up at
the net so a blast for everybody
involved these are a few moments from my
life thanks for watching
you